Thomas your sister bring the whole  greens they've seen things we have an  intruder on our land we have to find him  Thomas your sister she's gone  these people they're blasphemers occult  a disease bring her home named Thomas  Richardson a gleam of a world in which  each waking day we rise is pulled this  island it's our paradise we have an  intruder on our land we have to find him  you raised they've seen things  who are you he shall be cleansed  according to the Edict of this land the  promise of the divine is but an illusion  God is pain God is suffering  beware false prophets which come to you  in sheep's clothing but inwardly they  are ravening rules let us begin  [Applause]  [Music]  you